thoughts to all those that have been
affected by last night's incidents and
and those who have been injured and seen
some of the really upsetting images on
social media and others our thoughts are
with them
police were called by staff at the O2
Academy on Stockwell Road last night at
about half past nine following Imports
of a large number of people who were
attempting to force entry to the venue
officers London Ambulance Service and
fire brigade all attended and found a
number of people with injuries believed
to have been caused by crushing and some
of the officers provided first aid and
CPR to members of the public in order to
save life eight people were taken to
hospital with injuries believed to have
been caused by crushing injuries three
are currently in a critical condition
and our thoughts and prayers are with
them and their families
an urgent investigation is currently
underway led by detectives on specialist
crime command and cordons remain in
place as you can see
and officers continue to work at the
scene and at the location
I'm sure you can appreciate this is
still a fast moving and evolving picture
um
involving and we're working to establish
the the events that led up to last
night's incident
we're also aware of a vast amount of
footage being shared on social media and
of course this will be examined as part
of the investigation along with
body-worn video that officers have as
well
and we're working incredibly closely
with our partners and community members
and we'd like to thank them for their
support so far in the investigation and
for people for coming forward with their
information
in relation to some of the images that
have been circulated on social media
which a member of the public is
currently under a view by our director
of Professional Standards and another
instance where a member of public has
seen to assault an officer has led to
one arrest of that member of the public
I can also confirm that Nano police dogs
or Dog Handlers at the scene last night
and
and also I'd like to just make the point
that um London has a number of concerts
and events that take place every single
day every single week and every single
year and these are run and organized by
event organizers and police presence is
not usual we were called to the scene
last night and working as I say with our
partners to establish the the cause of
last night's incident
finally we are establishing a online
port on our website later today we want
to urge as many members of the public
who attended you know over 4 000 people
who attended last night all the proven
to be Witnesses members of public who
have heard things seen things please
come forward we need your information
and please find out and establish what
happened as quickly as we can
and I say thank you very much and our
thoughts and prayers remain with all
those that have been protected